[Music]
think of you for us I mean guys got to
run back with liquids so exactly we got
to figure this out excellent man well
thank you very much for your time and
we're gonna send it back to the
[Music]
[Applause]
hey at the end of the day exactly so oh
that's a camera there there is a camera
there if F is a not a map awareness
right oke you know this is the story
this is the story right here Chris
she Randall Chris she please give it up
put Academy they've got to show us what
they can bring to the table
Nidalee he's gonna be the pick and ramus
North American Challenger Series finals
[Music]
and defeat Team Liquid Academy in Game
five a liquid feeling a little bit
faster than shaken up after that event
fool I mean they made it close you got
to give it back I think that's enough
time to smoke yeah but he came from the
bomb Jamal he can't find the bomb oh my
goodness someone finally got onto but
it's a guy without a kid no I'm like
yeah what a huge investment there though
that was a five piece three they do lose
their turf but Energy's got them all
really really low impact what style they
after worry about Soraka what impact
what do you what impact he goes in he
goes down for first blood combine he
does have a spot
um dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
Wow okay it's got 11 HP no just noticing
they have the double TP they open lanes
up this far they can make those plays
and come to it exactly they have the
double TP take it openly
oh my we're taking two Kiwis quick take
the turret so you get the gold back
right you do who's that top wave that
top wave is going to go straight into
that turret now the actual you're losing
experience on multiple members and
crumbs oh my god if crumbs dies here
oh my god oh my god Rhonda angry wait a
minute wait no one has HP though man
here's the thing like infer could still
win this they can't press that Molly
they can't really do anything they'll
have it is he's in for a purse what all
on Dennis in a one on two he's inside
the smoke deep using with a kid Dennis
he's gonna get the round oh my god Envy
oh and he gets to kill as well how on
earth did Envy throw that away you can't
just do what the cars did it create a
safe zone to hold the point with and
that is Lilian they all decide to reset
yeah now it's Bella in the 1v1 to try
and close this out again smugly bug be
playing it aggressively Novakovich
and life will close out not number one
oh wait what what happened oh no no oh
that is heartbreaking
[Applause]
yeah laksa will see all Yasuo comes in
mana hit the table so hard the camera
cut knock off
apparently we have pauses for days
already
you're gonna continue here with one more
match today though evil genius
mvp.phoenix and we're going to go
continue with that after a small break
so we'll see you soon soon